[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to bonehead of the week
um
we had we had a lot of boneheads this
week as we do every weekend
it was definitely one of those things
that were like last minute like oh [ __ ]
who's going to be who's the you know
dishonorable mention who's the alpha
cuck right right right well um we've got
some we've got some good
some good candidates and you guys went
to the poll let's let's look at the poll
here uh the poll was uh josh hawley of
course donald trump this is the first
time he's ever appeared yeah this is the
first time he's made a little cameo in
here i mean we can't really let's take
this uh banner down there we go that way
we can see the whole thing uh and then
thomas massey i think thomas massey has
been on once before have we ever had
josh holly on the bonus no uh
josh pornhub holly has not been on the
show yet thomas massey was on the show
when he decided to say hey there was a
school shooting you know what the best
thing i should do is send out a postcard
a christmas family card
that asks santa for more ammo
he was following the footsteps of our uh
our idiot
um
lauren bobert okay
well so what did he do this week because
i know i know he made a quote or quoted
something um but it was so weird and
it's been like a year ago right so he
shared an image and had a quote that
ended up that he said was one person but
ended up being uh a a uh
the neo-nazi and then on top of that the
image that was spread was actually so
there's a hand that's like pushing
people down right uh and it was actually
an image that was around uh originally
was made as a a child labor like child
labor was pushing like unfair labor act
kind of thing
um so not only did he misquote the
person
i'm gonna say he did it intentionally
because
these guys aren't all idiots right uh
and then on top well easy and easy easy
on the not all these
they're idiots i'm not saying all of
them
are smart
some of them know what they're doing
mm-hmm and are intentionally doing it
under the guise of like
let's rile up the base and they're the
ones saying it so i'm just reiterating
they're the same normalizing white
nationalism [ __ ] right right it's just
it's this slow walk to fascism that
they've
been that they've been doing and they've
been doing it for decades and just under
trump it's kind of like an overdrive you
know
but um so so we have we have the thomas
massey um i'm i'm not even gonna go
there because we're we're we're we're 36
years linked to this i mean just know
massey's a piece of [ __ ] that's all you
got to do tldr masterpieces
there you go uh now senator josh holly i
believe this is the first time he showed
up on bone of the week yeah he's yeah
yes uh josh holly
did you know that josh hawley and his
wife have a podcast and they talk about
their christian lives i was calling it
out the other day yeah i did not know
yeah don't go download that go down
do not do not go download that if you
give it downl reviews without watching
it of course yeah give it some horrible
[ __ ] reviews like negative six stars
or some [ __ ] um yeah go do that yeah
josh hawley is the center of my great
state missouri uh that [ __ ] he doesn't
even i'm so sorry did you know he didn't
even he doesn't live here
oh yeah i remember that yeah he doesn't
live there and then of course whenever
you know whenever republican does
something like hey you shouldn't do that
uh
people are like uh well show us where he
has to live there and it's like
what why are you why are you defending
someone that just has like a band in
your state he's living elsewhere but
you're totally okay with it i mean i
mean he grew up
i guess as a kid in missouri
and his his sister
lives in um the southwest part
you know what i'm going to start a
birther movement around josh hawley i
want to see i want to see if i can see
the birth certificate i want to see
hey i'm good with that i mean i think i
think we should that's a thing that we
should do
um
and you know i was kind of
disappointed that that josh hawley made
the bonehead contestant list and the
reason why he did is because um you know
he's putin's puppy right you know he was
really you know
he's all in for putin you know he
definitely he definitely wants putin to
take ukraine and he wants biden to lose
this war against putin yeah but the
thing is josh hawley is trying to use
his excuse of supporting putin under
this whole like we shouldn't support
nato anymore excuse and that's what all
of the republican base and his followers
are doing they're like oh yeah well
neo-liberalism you guys uh want to
support fascism and it's like dude
homie is a fascist right trying to
overthrow the us government right right
like
well and and just speaking of fascists
josh hawley nazi i mean the whole i wish
we had the picture right yeah
yeah no i always i've always said about
that picture where he's pumping the fist
that [ __ ] he really needs to get his
arms straight and get his fingers out
like yeah yeah hitler would be really
disappointed in that [ __ ] alpha cuck
yeah you know he's got a copy of
mineconf in the inner breast pocket
absolutely absolutely well i mean you
know right next to his pocket
constitution right right you know i mean
i mean every once in a while you're out
and about and you need some toilet paper
your pocket constitution to republicans
should work [ __ ] fantastic exactly so
um so uh josh hawley
you know obviously um he's definitely a
bonehead and an alpha cuck like i said i
wish i wish we would have had him like
as alpha cuck of the week but we we got
some other alpha cucks coming but he got
30 percent of the vote believe or not
again trump the child
josh
well they don't right right
i mean how could you but right but
but donald trump was out front the
entire time yeah i mean as soon as we
launched the poll it was like
right i mean right now again this is the
first time that the cheeto dust mobster
has ever appeared on the back of the
weekend and i actually like the picture
that you have um yeah you know it's i
always try to find the best photos of
people sometimes
this one i don't know somewhere on
google i googled it you know i i i don't
duck duck go gave you the the donald
trump i said
smile best man ever in the world and it
gave me this photo that's what it gave
you yeah so you know well
goes on bias
it is i hear that's what that's what
they say people small tech baby small
tech
oh
so so what did what did the [ __ ] uh
king of the boneheads donald trump do
this week that we got him on uh you know
he said a lot of [ __ ] quiet part out
loud mm-hmm he uh he tried to he was
like
you know uh
he goes um
mike
it was the newsmax
interview uh coupled with his statement
right right i mean
he basically was like listen guys we
should have overthrown
and overturned the election let's
overthrow the government he was
revealing you know the quiet part out
loud and uh of course his father's like
yeah totally it's great and then some
obviously anyone with a brains like
uh did he just say that because he i
think he just said that he just said it
right guys and that's why everyone's
like yo merrick garland hey you come
check it out he's admitting it you know
well i mean i mean you know and we
talked about this earlier in the week
when he released that statement
basically saying i wanted to overthrow
the government of the united states that
was the whole intention and mike pence
should have done that thing because he
should have and could have and would
have and it was worked
well you actually i sent it to you in a
dm i'm like have you seen this it was
like two minutes after it dropped yeah
and you're like how can i make this
funnier i'm like you can't it's not it's
like there's no parody it's not even a
thing that like like he would say
something and then what you would do is
like oh i tried to overthrow the united
states government and it wouldn't right
it wouldn't be it would you know
sometimes the original is the best type
of parody or satire right right i'm
trying to find this uh this video here
of this [ __ ] bonehead talking about
um
when he's talking about pardoning people
because that was the other that was the
other thing that he said oh yeah he was
gonna pardon all of the uh how he feels
that the j6
uh
insurrectionist should be pardoned
um
so i don't know i'm kind of curious to
see how these people now respond to that
interview to be like oh oh oh you know
with the blind faith that he's going to
come back or he's going to be reinstated
or re-elected and then all of a sudden
he's going to pardon those people so
i mean they don't make a deal i think
it's looking pretty bad for them in
terms of uh
their sentencing whether it's like a
like a you know a felony or they're
actually going to serve prison time well
i mean he had the [ __ ] chance though
right like he had the chance to party he
had two weeks to do something about it
and then in that time he decided to keep
fighting this election and taking money
and you know fraud people and
i mean i mean right so i mean he had the
chance to do this yeah yeah if he really
cared about these these insurrectionists
j6 crowd and wasn't just [ __ ]
uh just like word service you know to
people um he would have done something
right because technically he could have
now everyone would be like what the [ __ ]
is going on this is insane why is he
pardoning these people but if he really
wanted to he had two weeks to sit down
at his desk take that big fat sharpie
and sign his name on that paper you know
i'm still looking for this uh this video
that we've got actually you know what uh
let's see
i'm trying to find the one where he's on
stage um talking about the
the
the pardons at the rally
because i believe i believe at the rally
he was inciting violence right like that
was the whole point which is also the
you know he's got a lawsuit against him
right now for that very s for that very
thing
right and uh eric swalwell and a few
others are are bringing suit against him
for
january 6 for basically inciting
inciting violence in washington yeah
there's she's got lawsuits all over the
place right right well um here's i think
here here maybe the
let's see
let's see if we can get this uh going
here
there we go so this is the this is the
video where he's talking at the rally
about the pardon how many people have
been asking me about it
if i run and if i win
if i run and if i win yeah i like that i
like that if i run and if i if i'm not
in prison
just
we will treat them fairly
and if it requires pardons we will give
them pardons because they are being
treated so
unfairly and basically i mean in my view
because this is this is the [ __ ] he
would talk about his entire presidency
right go commit crimes you know he would
say it to border agents he would say it
to all these [ __ ] uh you know anyone
inside the administration he would even
say it that right like you know also i
want to know how they're being treated
unfairly
they committed a crime they're in prison
if they're treated unfairly then let's
look at all the people who are
incarcerated for [ __ ] uh having an
ounce of weed or something right like
let's let's talk about people who are
actually untreated unfairly not the
people that decided to break the windows
vandalize smear [ __ ] on the wall
you know cause death uh and try to
overthrow the government like if you're
going to compare
something here let's look at who's
actually being untreated unfairly right
now not these dumb [ __ ] who thought
that they could overthrow the government
by literally
punching their way through
you know doors and glass windows
right well and and again um
i i would
i would love to play tons of video and
there there is tons of video here on
this
but
he was even pissed off at lindsey graham
do you remember this during the
interview he was mad at of course i
think has lindsay lindsay's made it on
the bonehead of the week hasn't he so
far
i can't remember he was his photo was
oh yeah yeah he had a tongue in the out
of the mouth lipstick yeah so so lindsey
was on at some point but yeah but trump
was really upset
um at lindsay yeah um
and the reason why is because lindsey
graham
uh basically because they were talking
about uh the scotus pick right is that
is that the is that the situation yeah
that's it's basically every republican
out there right now is making the same
argument right oh how dare joe biden say
that he's going to elect
uh a black female nominee right
but yeah it is one of those things i
mean even donald trump jr was on some
fox show the other day where he was
talking about lindsey graham he's like
oh he's great but he's a rhino and it's
like
you guys just don't like when you guys
don't agree you just [ __ ] on each other
in front of everyone else
well i mean that's that's how they do
now we have um we have uh not that not
to skip over him because i'll give him
his due here in a second we're 47
minutes in the hour so i want to i want
to move ahead here to uh the
dishonorable mention of courses
the constitutionalist herself right how
many boneheads has she actually has she
actually won like she's
i think she's definitely been
dishonorable mentioned a couple of times
like she's
she's consistent
right well i mean
i mean the definite definite definite
bonehead and a constant um
uh member of the bonehead of the week
probably um she could be like a an
alumnus yeah
but um here here here we'll pull up the
reason why we put her on uh dishonorable
mention i think she'd retweeted there
she tweeted this stupid [ __ ] last night
and i'm gonna i'm gonna tell her her
[ __ ] tweet sucks here your tweet
sucks i love the fact so i made it i did
a tweet last night that yes i wanted to
do a quote
a quote tweet of it and uh
i said all right who's going to tell or
who's going to explain
you know amendments to representative
lauren bobert right right because
there's there's this argument that
people have it's like oh is the
constitution a living document or is it
an original document that is supposed to
be
you know static in its place
and people always try to you know
obviously some people on the supreme
court believe it's one way and some
people on the supreme court believe it's
another way but here's the thing
if
you know the constitution isn't ideal
it's an idea right and ideas change over
time if you really wanted it to be true
to the constitution we wouldn't have
many things that we have today right uh
like lauren bobert wouldn't be able to
vote that's just that's just a fact
right like that's well there is there is
this thing called the second uh
amendment that she talks about a lot
right
they love their first they love the
second oh well you're right that's well
they can only go that far and they don't
even know what those two say and this
morning i tweeted
i tweeted excuse me i tweeted uh
wouldn't you like or who would like to
see us uh second grader explain the word
amendment uh to lauren
because she really she doesn't [ __ ]
get it she never gets it and sometimes i
think like her team's like how stupid
can you tweet this today so that you
trend and you end up on the tony
michaels podcast bonehead of the week
like how can we get on bonehead of the
week i really feel like she she really
tries her god damned to get on the
percent she and i don't even know if she
tries too hard she's like i just you
know it's like i woke up this way and
it's like
cool you [ __ ] idiot well you know
that happens uh we also
last couple weeks um we've been doing
um you coined the
yeah alpha cuts so we've been doing
alpha of the week
and we had someone who uh i i think they
went on sean hannity last night was the
was the thing that that happened um but
uh um adam corolla
yeah
oh i spelled his name wrong is it oh
well corolla like toyota carroll yeah
yeah yeah yeah well yeah my bad i don't
care i'm sorry sorry adam we we really
we really tried to work you on the show
and get your name right but uh you alpha
cucked it you know what what ends up
happening is i couldn't find a shitty
photo of him so i misspelled his name
god damn it son of a [ __ ]
son of a [ __ ]
well i don't feel bad about it it
happened it happened yeah [ __ ] them all
right so um this is this is the reason
why
uh adam carol and i uh let's see i think
this is is this the video i just want to
double check here
uh yes this is this is the aoc video
he's talking about aoc he's on sean
hannity they were being [ __ ] racist
and sexist yeah yeah you know they had
to cuck it out here on the um
on the sean hannity's fox news let's
listen here's a quick thought experiment
if aoc
was fat and in her 60s would anyone
listen to another thing she ever said so
basically before he gets started here
because he really he not only says i
mean right there is enough to be on
alpha cuck of the week right right like
just that
he just went out
all right
he's like oh i've heard of this show and
they do the bonus of the week but i
wasn't a contestant i really need to get
alpha cuck
i realized that would make me an
official candidate for the show i know
well you know maybe one of these days
they'll like say that live on aaron fox
news oh that's going to get me off of
cook of the week yeah i know yeah right
we could get people to use the show
his argument here is is that women and
especially uh women of color
don't have enough brains that you know
if obviously if she's not cute and
pretty which aoc is a beautiful she's a
beautiful woman you know i don't think
anyone right but
the thing is i think most people like
what she has to say
not i mean they probably a lot of people
like how she looks she's again she's a
gorgeous a gorgeous young woman
but
they listen to what she says because how
she says it and the words that she
[ __ ] uses right it's not because she
looks pretty which she is by the way but
that's not the thing that's not what
matters here it's the fact that she can
actually
hold her own
and state
the things in an intelligent way and
actually have fact behind it right right
and whether you agree with her or not
like yeah you know there are a lot of
things that i agree with aoc and there
are some things that i don't exactly
agree with her on like i'm not i'm not
there on some things but here's the
thing it's like most people look at her
as like this extreme radical or
something like that and it's really
funny how they're like they're like
pointing out how gorgeous she is right
right um and and and
that's the typical thing they'll do
they'll go with the uh looks you mean
when they're alpha cucking is that what
you mean right yeah they are right
they'll target the appearance first
before they touch anything else oh well
you know it happens with these alright i
don't even know that we have to go any
further with his statements here but i'm
going to play just a bit because watch
sean hannity really kind of freak out
here yeah oh boy you're going to step in
that one
oh boy you're going to get alpha [ __ ] of
the week
you're on the tony michaels podcast oh
my god you're getting get alpha cuck
today exactly do you mean by that
do you mean is it because she's young
and
what what
yeah she's young she's vibrant she's
beautiful and everyone's okay sean is
like oh you [ __ ] what are you what do
you mean by that yeah and you like how
they like go back to they go to all
three like what do you mean by that and
they're like oh he's gonna double down
all right
let's let's and let's play the video of
her looking looking beautiful but saying
smart [ __ ] into a microphone
we're just gonna mute a mic right in her
face but
her opinions are idiotic 95 of the time
which i mean you know well fair enough
if you don't like her ideas fair enough
but to act like she's just some [ __ ]
idiot and doesn't know what she's
talking about misogynistic type of
arguments against someone and not go
against the actual ideas or statements
right
yeah i mean
this is this is alpha cocking 101 right
exactly
how do i get off on shooting on someone
else and we're going to make this at
this alpha cooking thing let's let's
listen here and i don't think if she was
a middle-aged he doesn't think which is
is appropriate heavy but again woman
anyone would care what she had to say so
if she was he did not just say that
twice
right well i mean the same thing again
he has nothing to add to the actual
thing well how could he how could he add
anything to this conversation when he's
basically saying
when he's basically saying if you're a
woman as long as you're pretty people
will listen which is [ __ ] just
completely um alpha cucking in and of
itself and it only proves that these
[ __ ] boneheads are terrified
terrified not of women but beautiful
women because like oh my god if you're
smart and you're good looking like
they're thinking if i'm in a this is
this whole eminem and sex isn't sexy
thing right this stuff i'm in a bar
and i see a very gorgeous woman and then
she can outsmart me how in the hell am i
going to manage
how the hell am i going to manage around
this person
how do i exist in a world of smart
intelligent funny good-looking
charismatic women who can [ __ ] hold
their own and march of their own beat
and then these you know white fragile
men who's like oh the first thing is
attack how they look right right right
well not attack how they look how attack
how they how they should look like smart
women smart women shouldn't be beautiful
right they should be
fat old and whatever middle age and
whatever right it's like oh we're just
gonna dedicate
like like adam corolla is he's not even
middle aged anymore like yeah
yeah he's you know he's getting there to
geriatric right right he's gotta have
the glasses on he's got the gray hair i
mean he wears glasses all the time
like every interview i see with him now
he's always wearing the glasses and then
it casts a shadow down where he looks
even older and creepier right right
he is old and creepy
speaking old and creepy sp let's give
our winner the cheeto dust mobster
grandpa poopypants the orange mussolini
jesus let's give him his new since he
won this week let's give him his dude
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
i wonder i wonder what goes i wonder
what goes in there that looks like a
that looks like a holster or something
anyways
speaking of alpha cooks um maybe a
derringer goes in there well it could be
yeah you know it couldn't call call back
to the interview if anyone's me i mean
now you know go watch the interview we
just did with uh with tasha and dakota
adams shout out on the bonehead of the
week for the interview yeah so
go to
at tony michael's pod we're gonna have
uh the poll up for this week we'll
probably get it over the weekend we'll
have plenty of boneheads over the
weekend to put on the pole so go follow
tony michael's pod you can you can vote
there and then we'll do bonehead of the
week in the second hour of the podcast
uh every friday and remember the podcast
starts every single weekday noon eastern
11 central for two hours right here on
youtube twitter twitch thanks thanks for
hanging for bonehead of the week hang
around right after the song we'll talk
more about the interview
[Music]
[Applause]